what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to the rumor roundup our
weekly series where we cover all the
news and rumors that you may have missed
over the course of the week and this is
a special episode because we've got like
four days four let's see monday tuesday
wednesday thursday four days until
spider-man no way home comes out
although if you are going to see it on
like the midnight showing release day i
think you're seeing it on wednesday i
think we're seeing it on wednesday on
the 16th regardless we're gonna cover
all the news and rumors or at least all
the really good ones anyway regarding
spider-man no way home so you can kind
of put it all together and then get a
better idea of what to expect by the
time the movie comes out so let's start
well let's start with the stuff we hate
the debunked rumors
the ones that we know are not true and
let's kick things off here with the
rumor that kirsten dunst is going to
appear in spider-man no way home now
this rumor circulated because there was
a picture that featured kirsten dutst
and deborah ann wall walking on what
appeared to be the set of spider-man no
way home and it circulated around pretty
fast i'm sure a lot of you guys recall
that people were like oh my god they're
going to be in the movie and so kirsten
had an interview with total film where
she was like no i'm not appearing in
spider-man no way home and she even kind
of made a little bit of a joke about it
right she's basically like i'd be like
old mj with like little kids and
spiderman and stuff like that right so i
mean it's kind of cool but at that
instance at that point in time people
sort of took it with a grain of salt and
the reason why is because with something
like andrew garfield for example we all
pretty much believe he's going to appear
in that movie and it's all but been
confirmed however andrew garfield has
stood fast in saying he's not going to
show up in that film there's been other
instances in the past when that's been
the case right like the loki tv show and
jonathan majors coming out and saying no
i'm not appearing in the loki tv show i
don't know why people keep asking me
that and then he shows up in the end as
a mortise which took everybody by
surprise so you can't necessarily take
what actors say as an absolute truth
because they obviously can't spoil the
film itself however this confirmation
that kirsten dunst is not going to
appear in spider-man no way home seem to
come by way of daniel rpk who as most of
you guys know we use as a primary source
for a lot of our information because
he's almost always right and he
basically came out and said no like
kirsten dunst is not going to be in that
same film that leads us into our next
debunked rumor which is deborah and wall
was supposed to appear in spider-man no
way home now for those of you guys who
don't know who she is she played karen
page in the daredevil series now as much
as i love the character of karen page if
we're all being honest with ourselves
while it would have been cool to see
deborah and wall in spiderman no way
home i think most people were excited
about that prospect because with karen
page comes daredevil and so having her
in the film would mean daredevil was
virtually guaranteed and we would
basically see him in the movie if she
was going to be in the film however she
also came out recently and so did daniel
rpk and saying deborah and wall is not
going to be
in this film so a little bit of a
letdown for those of you guys who are
karen page fans now following this this
goes into what is a pretty interesting
if not a little weird of a rumor which
was that emma stone was gonna show back
up as gwen stacy
in spiderman no way home i mean what
role is she gonna play she died in
andrew garfield's spider-man like
amazing spider-man 2 she died so unless
mephisto sees control of her body and
started like parading her around in
front of andrew garfield like andrew
garfield look i died and you couldn't
save me
unless something like that happens i
don't really see
her having any kind of a role in this
film if we did end up seeing emma stone
which in all honesty i think we probably
will it won't be her which is like
andrew garfield and her in some kind of
a scene it'll be a flashback so likely
it'll just be scenes from amazing
spider-man 2 when she died that's when
you will basically end up seeing her
right because if andrew garfield really
is in this movie and we know toby
maguire is going to be in this movie
that andrew and toby and tom holland
will likely have some kind of a powwow
where like they tell their stories about
how they struggle and all that kind of
stuff and the failures over their
careers and so on so which we all want
to see right we want to see these guys
just kind of hang out and basically talk
to each other for a little while that
andrew garfield will likely talk about
the biggest failure of his career which
was the death of emma stone's gwen stacy
and so you'll likely see flashbacks to
that whole encounter when she basically
ended up dying when she was falling from
the bell tower so again that's probably
the extent that we're going to see of
her character but again for the most
part it's kind of confirmed she's not
going to be there now the last rumor and
i don't even know where this came from i
don't even know where this rumor came
from supposedly harry holland was
supposed to play ben riley and
spider-man knowing him i don't know how
this gained popularity i don't know why
a game well i know why he gained
popularity ben riley is a clone of peter
parker but like it's way too soon to do
something like that in spider-man right
to basically start like introducing the
clone saga it's way too too early for
that kind of a thing like we don't have
miles warren right there's no jackal
there's no reason to start bringing in
clones right it's just it's way too
early for that whole thing so that's
probably something that is totally
untrue i mean i don't know if there's
really been anything per se to say that
it's not true but it just seems so
ridiculous at least to do it in this
film it might as well not be true
however that brings us into
our unconfirmed rumors which are
basically rumors that no one's bothered
to say are true or not true i guess we
could do confirmed rumors but that just
sounds like watch time for me or hey
guys uh doctor strange is supposed to
appear in spider-man no way home
so that's a confirmed rumor right wong's
gonna be in the movie
that's confirmed you know tom holland is
gonna play spider-man mj's gonna return
and jacob babylon's gonna be there
confirmed rumors i mean there's no point
in running over confirmed rumors we
already know they're true however this
first one
is a cool one so the unconfirmed rumor
is that matt murdock will appear in
spider-man no way home
i don't know if that's true or not but i
really hope it is if i'm being honest
with you guys if that was going to be
the case he would probably appear pretty
early on and his role would be a small
one right i can't imagine like daredevil
jumping in in the middle of everything
and like fighting the sinister six
alongside all three spider-man it'd be
cool
it'd be really cool
[Laughter]
but we don't know if matt murdock is
going to appear in spiderman no way home
the closest we've gotten to this is
kevin feige coming out and saying yes
matt murdock is going to appear in the
marvel cinematic universe and charlie
cox will play the character that's all
we've gotten right so this is basically
an unconfirmed rumor where it's not
really being said one way or the other
like fighting them have not come out and
said no matt murdock is not going to
appear in spider-man no way home but
they haven't come out and said he is
going to appear in spider-man their way
home so it can kind of go one way or the
other i think most all of us can agree
we want to see him in spider-man no way
home so again it's just one of those
unconfirmed things now the next rumor
that we have is one that we've talked
about before and you guys had very
varying opinions on it which is that
little nos x was going to be playing
miles morales now this ties into another
rumor which is a pretty important one
that miles morales will be name dropped
in spider-man no way home and it kind of
makes sense right we know that like
donald glover played uncle aaron and
spider-man homecoming uncle aaron being
the uncle of miles morales that he made
reference to his nephew that was not
necessarily a guarantee because the
marvel cinematic universe changes things
all the time so just because things were
a certain way in the comics does not
mean they were going to be that way in
the marvel cinematic universe but we
hadn't necessarily heard anything that
even debunked it right it was just like
i have a nephew and anybody who is
familiar with the character of uncle
aaron and miles morales immediately
picked up on that right we're like oh my
god it's miles more alice but it looks
like in spider-man no way home miles
will be name dropped now the other thing
about this is apparently he will not be
seen we will not actually see what miles
morales looks like and so again that
goes into the rumor that little nos x is
the one playing miles morales now
apparently little knots actually tweeted
out this image where he was hanging out
with tom holland and andrew garfield and
he was like the rumors are true i'm
going to be playing my optimal house
what rumors i have not heard any rumors
right i mean what is it like what's like
umbrella academy like i heard a rumor
that little knot's ex was going to be
playing miles morales like i don't know
if that's i i hadn't heard anything that
that was going to be the case however he
tweeted a picture out with the two of
them and said yes i'm going to be
playing miles morales now again the
response to this i wouldn't really say
is one of like vitriol it's one of
people who were just like not a chance
or people who are just like i could see
that it seems to kind of go either way
honestly i don't know i mean i'm not too
picky about who plays miles morales so
long as we get him i would prefer the
person they bring in to play the
character does match the ethnicities of
miles morales in the sense that miles is
half black half puerto rican so i would
love to see that i'd love to see that
kind of element brought together so the
actor that plays the character actually
reflects the ethnicities of the
character but by and large i just want
to see miles so even just getting him
name dropped here would be a pretty
amazing thing now beyond that i'm not
aware of any rumors in terms of how he
gains powers if he gains powers if it'll
happen anytime soon any post credit
scenes or anything along those lines but
regardless the next rumor that we have
here is that tom hardy will appear as
venom
in spiderman no way home now this is a
bit of a murky thing right this is a bit
of a murky rumor here and the reason why
is because we know that venom is in the
marvel cinematic universe we know that
because of the ending of venom 2 that he
was yanked in to the mcu and in all
honesty if you really read between the
lines and you really look at the ending
of venom 2 and then you look at the
trailers for what's going on with
spider-man no way home venom 2 basically
gave us the answer to why all the
villains are there but the important
thing here is that tom hardy is supposed
to appear in this film in what capacity
i don't know in all honesty
i don't see peter getting the venom
symbiote in this movie largely because
of the fact that like andy serkis the
director of venom came out recently and
said hey look if venom and and
spider-man are going to meet it's not
going to be some kind of quick one-off
event that happens in like at like the
tail end of the trilogy of spider-man
movies from the marvel cinematic
universe it's gonna be a thing right
it's gonna be like a big thing the whole
movie is going to be based around
spider-man and venom meeting each other
and rightfully so right because it's one
of the most anticipated things to happen
with the character in the marvel
cinematic universe spider-man getting
the venom symbiote having said that
there are rumors circulating around on
the post-credits scenes of spider-man no
way home which is that for whatever
reason however things end up working out
that venom will be sent back to his own
universe but a piece of the symbiote
will remain behind and that will
basically set up the next spider-man
trilogy which is where peter ends up
bonding to the venom symbiote and that
unfolds however it is that it unfolds as
far as i'm aware we're a few years out
from the beginnings of the next
spider-man uh trilogy right like we're a
few years out from just that first movie
and that new set of three movies so
there's a lot of stuff that can happen
between now and then and as most of you
guys know when it comes to the
post-credit scenes involving movies they
usually tie into what's going on at the
time in terms of how the character will
fit into it all especially if what's
going on in that individual character or
teams movie does not pertain to the
larger overarching theme right so i
could definitely see some kind of a
post-credit scene that may involve venom
that might most likely involve something
akin to like doctor strange too that
ties into what's going to be going on in
that movie now there are a couple other
rumors i guess maybe honorable mentions
that are worth bringing up paul giamatti
is supposed to return his rhino cool i
guess and then also mj is supposed to be
saved by like andrew garfield spider-man
in that scene when like she's falling
from the
i guess big structure big construction
site basically and it looks like she's
gonna fall to her death pretty much in
the exact same way that like gwen stacy
did in the comics and the way she did in
andrew garfield's universe and that
basically andrew garfield saving mj is
gonna be him kind of redeeming himself
and basically kind of fixing the mistake
that he made before where he can finally
get to her in time and basically save
her life i wouldn't be surprised if like
she's an instant from hitting the ground
when he saves her kind of building up
that suspense again we don't necessarily
know if that's the case but some of the
biggest rumors slash leaks pertaining to
this film which are huge
circle around the green goblin so we
know that willem dafoe is going to
appear as the green goblin and spiderman
no way home right we know that from the
trailers we know that from just the the
villain interviews and all that kind of
stuff we know that's going to happen
one of the other big rumors circulating
around is that dame dehaan is going to
show back up in this movie as a second
green goblin so that we're supposedly
going to be getting two now i don't know
if that's the case what we have when it
comes to the trailers and whatnot is
you've got the classic green goblin as
willem dafoe appeared and sam remy's
spider-man 1 and then you've got what
looks like a more updated depiction of
green goblin as it's potentially being
portrayed by dane d han if i'm being
honest with you guys i don't really
think that's the case i think it's more
just willem dafoe's updated look in the
same way that dr octopus gets an updated
look and elektro gets an updated look
lizard doesn't really get one because
he's just a giant lizard how do you
update the look of the lizard i mean
it's a guy who turns into a lizard man
sandman's the exact same way right he's
just a giant sand guy i mean i don't
know how you really update the
technology of those individual
characters but it looks to me like it's
just willem dafoe as a green goblin
having said that it is possible dane d
han could appear so i wouldn't write
that off completely again this is
unconfirmed no one said it's not true
and no one said it is true by and large
it's just one of those things that could
potentially happen but another big rumor
here this is one that's been circulating
around for a long long time
is that mj while it does look like she's
going to be saved by andrew garfield
spider-man that basically keeps her from
the the jaws of death on may will not be
so fortunate that the rumors and leaks
are suggesting aunt may will die in
spider-man no way home and that will
basically leave peter parker with his
biggest failure which is that he
couldn't save aunt may's life now this
is particularly important and the reason
why is because as far as i'm aware we
still don't know what happened with
uncle ben we know uncle ben died but we
don't know if uncle ben died as a result
of peter's negligence that he could have
stopped a criminal and instead he didn't
and because that criminal escaped that
criminal in turn killed uncle ben and so
peter had to basically deal with that
fallout that as far as we're aware with
the uncle ben roll in the marvel
cinematic universe he's a guy that
helped to take care of peter and peter
really really loved him but there
doesn't really seem to be that kind of
gravitas that like i don't want a
situation like uncle ben to happen again
and so if aunt may died the death of
aunt may would basically replace the
death of uncle ben in the marvel
cinematic universe in terms of the
significance and the gravity involving
the character of spider-man it kind of
makes sense there again this is all
unconfirmed stuff we don't know if any
of this is true or false it's just
things that potentially may happen over
the course of this movie at the end of
the day we won't necessarily know until
the movie comes out or until somebody
comes out and like debunks all this
stuff so let me know what you guys think
about these things down in the comments
section do you guys believe they're true
do you believe they're false did we get
something wrong let us know down in the
comments thank you guys for watching and
we will catch you all later peace